let's talk about the assembly
equation okay how should we do this all
let me just even read that part of the
paper we Define assembly as the total
amount of selection necessary to produce
an ensemble of observed objects
Quantified using equation
one the equation basically has a on one
side which is the Assembly of The
Ensemble MH and then a
sum from one to n where n is the total
number of unique
objects and then there is a few
variables in there that include the
assembly
index the copy number which we'll talk
about that's an interesting I don't
remember you talking about that that's
an interesting addition and I think a
powerful one has to do with what that
you can create pretty complex objects
randomly mhm and in order to know that
they're not random that there's a
factory involved you need to see a bunch
of them that's that's the intuition
there it's an interesting intuition and
then uh some
normalization what else is it n n minus
one just to make sure that more than one
object one object could be a one of and
random yep and then you have more than
one identical object that's interesting
when when there's when there's two of a
thing two of a thing is super important
especially if the in index assembly
index is high so uh we could say several
questions here one let's talk about
selection what is this term selection
what is this term evolution that we're
referring to which which aspect of
darwinian evolution I'll be referring to
that's interesting here so yeah so this
is probably what you know the paper we
should talk about the pay for a second
the paper did what it did is it kind of
annoyed um we didn't know I mean it got
intention and obviously angry people the
angry people were annoyed there's angry
people in the world that's good so what
happened is the evolutionary biologist
got angry we were not expecting that cuz
we thought evolutionary biologies would
be cool I knew that some not many
computational complexity people will get
angry because i' kind of been poking
them and maybe I deserved it but I was
trying to poke them in a productive way
MH and then the physicist kind of got
grumpy because the initial conditions
tell everything the Prebiotic chemist
got slightly grumpy because there's not
enough chemistry in there then finally
when the creationist said it wasn't
creationist enough I was like right I've
done my job the phys you're saying the
physics they
say because you're basically saying that
physics is not enough to tell the story
of how biology emerges I think so and
then they said a few physics is the
beginning and the end of the story yeah
so what happened is the reason why
people put the phone down on the call of
the paper if you if you view reading the
paper like a phone call they got to the
abstract yep and in the abstract it's
first sentence is pretty first two
sentences caused everybody s have
grappled with reconciling biological
evolution with the immutable laws of the
universe defined by physics true right
there's nothing wrong with that
statement totally
true yeah these laws underpin life's
origin Evolution and the development of
human culture and Technology yet they do
not predict the emergence of these
phenomena Wow first all we should say
the title of the paper this is paper was
accepted and published in nature the
title is a assembly Theory explains and
quantifies selection and evolution very
humble title and and the the the
entirety of the paper I think uh
presents interesting ideas but reaches
High I am
not I would do it all again this paper
was actually on the pre-print server for
over a year you regret nothing yeah I I
I think yeah I don't regret anything
Frank Sinatra did it your way what I
love about being a scientist is kind of
sometimes I'm cuz I'm a bit dim I'm like
and I don't understand what people
telling me I want to get to the point
this paper says Hey laws of physics are
really cool the universe is
great but they don't really it's not
intuitive that you just run the standard
model and get life out I think most
physicists might go yeah there's this
you know it's not just we can't just go
back and say that's what happened
because physics can't explain the origin
of life yet do doesn't mean it won't or
can't okay just to be clear sorry
intelligent designers we are going to
get there second point we say that
Evolution works but we don't know how
Evolution got going so biological
evolution and biological selection so
for me this seems like a simple
Continuum so when I mentioned selection
and evolution in the title I think and
in the abstract we should have maybe
prefaced that and said non-biological
selection and non-biological evolutions
and then that might have made it even
more crystal clear but I didn't think
that biology evolutionary biology should
be so bold to claim ownership of
selection and evolution and secondly a
lot of evolutionary biologists seem to
dismiss the origin of Life questions
just say it's obvious and and that
causes a real problem scientifically
because when two different when the
physicists are like we own the universe
universe is good we explain all of it
look at us and the biologists say we can
explain biology and the poor chemistry
in the in in the middle ground but hang
on MH and paper kind of says heyy there
is an
interesting
um disconnect between physics and
biology and that's at the point which
memories get made in chemistry through
bonds and hey let's look at this close
and see if we can quantify it so yeah I
mean I never expected the paper to to to
kind of get that much interest and still
I mean it's only been published just
over a month ago now so just to Ling on
the selection what is the
broader sense of what selection means
yeah that's really good for selection
selection so I think for selection you
need so this is where for me the concept
of an object is something that can
persist in time and and not die but
basically can be broken up MH so so if I
was going to kind of bolster the
definition of an object so so if and if
something can
form and persist for a a long period of
time um
under an existing environment that could
destroy other and I'm going to use
anthropomorphic terms I apologize but
weaker objects um or less
robust um then the environment could
have selected that so good chemistry
example if you took some carbon and you
made a chain of carbon atoms whereas if
you took some I don't know some carbon
nitrogen and oxygen and made chain from
those you'd start to get different
reactions and rearrangements so a carb a
chain of carbon atoms might be more
resistant to falling apart uh under
acidic or basic conditions um versus
another set of molecules so survives in
that environment so the acid Pond the
molecule the the molecule the resistant
molecule can get through and and then
then that molecule goes into another
environment so that environment now
maybe being an acid Bond it's a basic
Bond or maybe it's an oxidizing Pond and
so if you've got carbon and it goes in
oxidizing pond maybe the carbon starts
to oxidize and break apart so you go
through all these kind of obstacle
courses if you like given by reality so
selection is the ability happens when
object survives in an environment for
some time but and this is a thing that's
super subtle the object has to be
continually being destroyed and made by
process so it's not not just about the
proc the object now it's about the
process and time that makes it cuz a
rock could just stand on the mountain
side for 4 billion years and nothing
happened to it and that's not
necessarily really Advanced selection so
for selection to get really interesting
you need to have a turnover in time you
need to be continually creating objects
producing them what we call Discovery
Time so there's a discovery time for an
object when that object is discovered if
it's say a molecule that can then act on
itself or the chain of events that
caused itself to bolster its formation
then you go from Discovery time to
production time and suddenly you have
more of it in the universe so it could
be a self-replicating molecule and the
interaction of a molecule in the
environment in the warm Little Pond or
in the sea or wherever in the bubble
could then start to build a Proto
Factory the environment so really to
answer your question what the factory is
the factory is the environment but it's
not very autonomous it's not very
redundant there's lots of things that
could go wrong so once you get high
enough up the the the hierarchy of
networks of
interactions something needs to happen
that needs to be compressed into a
smaller volume and made resistant robust
because in biology selection and
evolution is robust that you have error
correction built in you have really you
know there's good ways of basically
making sure propagation goes on so
really the difference between inorganic
abiotic selection and evolution and
evolution and stuff in biology is
robustness um the ability to to kind of
propagate over over in the the ability
survive in lots of different
environments whereas our poor little
inorganic salt molecule whatever just
dies in lots of different environments
so there's something super special that
happens from the inorganic envir
molecule in the environment that kills
it to where you've got Evolution and
cells can survive
everywhere how special is that how do
you know those kinds of uh Evolution
factors aren't everywhere in the
universe I I don't and I'm excited
because I think selection isn't special
at all I think what is special is the
history of the environments on Earth
that gave rise to the first cell that
now has you know has taken all those
environments and is now more autonomous
and I would like to think that you know
this
paper could be very
wrong but I don't think it's very wrong
I mean it's certainly wrong but it's
less wrong than some other ideas I hope
right and if this allow inspires us to
go and look for selection in the
universe because we now have an equation
where we can say we can look for
selection going on and say oh that's
interesting we seem to have a pro
process that's giving that's giving us
High copy number objects also are highly
complex but that doesn't look like Life
as We Know It And we use that and say oh
there's a hydrothermal vent oh there's a
process going on those molecular
networks because the assembly equation
is not only meant to identify at the
higher end
Advanced selection what you get I would
call in biology you super Advanced
selection and even I you could use the
assembly equation to look for technology
and um God forbid we could talk about
Consciousness and abstraction but let's
keep it primitive molecules and biology
so I think the real power of the
assembly equation is to is to say how
much selection is going on in this space
and there's there's a really simple
thought experiment I could do is you you
know have a little petri dish and on
that petri dish you put some simple food
so the assembly index of all the sugars
and everything is quite low so then and
you put a single Eco cell of e eoli cell
yeah and then you say I'm going to I'm
going to measure the assembly in the
amount of assembly in the box so it's
quite low
but the rate of change of assembly da DT
will go Voom sigmoidal as it eats all
the food and the number of coli cells
will re will replicate because they take
all the food they copy themselves the
assembly index of all the molecules goes
up up up and up until the food is
exhausted in the box so now the now the
eoli stop I mean dye is probably a
strong word they stop respiring because
all the food is gone but suddenly the
amount of assembly in the box has gone
up gigantically because of the that one
eoli Factory has just eaten through M
lots of other eoli Factory and run out
of food and stopped and so that looking
at that so in the initial box although
the amount of assembly was really small
it was able to replicate and use all the
food and go up and that's what we're
trying to do in the lab actually is kind
of make those kind of experiments and
see if we can spot the emergence of
molecular networks that are producing
complexity as we feed in raw materials
and we feed a challenge an environment
you know we try and kill the molecules
and and and really that's the main kind
of idea for the entire paper yeah and
see if you can measure the changes in
the assembly index throughout the whole
system yeah okay what what about if if I
show up to new planet we go to Mars or
some other planet from a different solar
system and how do we use assembly index
there to discover alien life um in very
simply actually if we let's say we'll go
to Mars with a mass spectrometer with a
sufficiently high resolution so what you
have to be able to do so good thing
about Mass speec um is that you can um
select a molecule from the mass and then
if it's high enough resolution you can
be more and more sure that you're just
seeing um identical copies you can count
them and then you fragment them and you
count the number of fragments and look
at the molecular weight and the higher
the molecular weight and the higher the
number of fragments the higher the
assembly index so if you go to Mars and
you take a mass spec or high enough
resolution and you can find molecules
I'll give gu guide on Earth if you could
find molecules say greater than 350
molecular weight with more than 15
fragments you have found artifacts that
can only be produced at least on Earth
by life now you would say oh well maybe
the geological process I would argue
very vly that that is not the case but
we can say look if you don't like the
cut off on
Earth go up higher 30 100 right because
there's going to be a point where you
can find a molecule so many different
parts the chances of you getting a
molecule that has a 100 different parts
um and finding a million identical
copies you know that's that's just
impossible that could never happen in an
infinite set of universes can you just
Linger on this copy number
thing uh a million different copies
what do you mean by copies and why is
the number of copies
important yeah that was so interesting
and that um
I always understood the copy number was
really important but I never explained
it properly for ages um and it be I kept
having this it goes back to this if I
give you a um I don't know a really
complicated molecule and I say it's
complicated you could say hey that's
really complicated but is it just really
random MH and so so I realized that
ultimate Randomness and ultimate
complexity are
indistinguishable
until you can um you can see a structure
in the randomness so you can see copies
so copies
implies structure
yeah the factory I mean there's a deep
profound thing in there cuz like if you
just have a
random random process process you're
going to get a lot of complex beautiful
sophisticated things mhm what makes
them complex in the way we think life is
complex or um yeah something like a a
factory that's operating under a
selection processes there should be
copies is there like some looseness
about copies
like what does it mean for two objects
to be equal it it's it's all to do with
the the telescope or the microscope
you're using and so at the the maximum
resolution so in the nice thing about
the nice thing about chemists is they
have this concept of the molecule and
they're all familiar with a molecule and
molecules you can hold you know on your
hand lots of them identical copies and
molecules actually a super important
thing in chemistry to say look you can
have a mole of a molecues an avagadro's
number of molecules and they're
identical what does that mean that means
that the molecular composition the
bonding and so on the configuration is
all is is indistinguishable you can hold
them together you can overlay them so
the way I do it is if I say here's a bag
um of 10 identical molecules let's prove
they're identical you pick one out of
the the out of the bag and you basically
observe it using some technique and then
you put it you take it away and then you
take another one out if You observe it
using techque you see no differences
they're identical it's really
interesting to get right because if you
take say two molecules molecules can be
in different vibrational rotational
States they're moving all the time so
for this respect identical molecules
have identical bonding in this case we
don't even um talk about chirality
because we don't have a chirality
detector so two identical molecules in
one conception assembly Theory basically
um considers both hands as being the
same um but of but of course they're not
they're different as soon as you have a
chyro distinguisher detect to detect the
left and the right hand they become
different and so it's to do with the
detection system that you have and the
resolution so I wonder if there's in Art
and Science to the which detection
system is used when you show up to a new
planet yeah yeah yeah so like you're
talking about chemistry a lot today we
have kind of standardized detection
systems right of how to compare
molecules so you know when you start to
talk about emojis and language and uh
mathematical theorems
and uh I don't know more sophisticated
things at a different scale at a smaller
scale molecules that are largest scale
of the
molecules like what
detection like if if we look at the
difference between you and me
lxly are we the same are we different
sure I mean of course we're different
close up but if you zoom out a little
bit will morphologically look the same
yeah you know height and characteristics
hair length stuff like that also like
the species and yeah yeah yeah and and
also there's a sense why we're both from
Earth
yeah I I agree I mean this is the power
of assembly theory in that regard that
you if if you so if everything so the
way to look at it if you have a box of
objects if they're all if they're all
indistinguishable um then using your
Technique you then you what you then do
is you then look at the assembly index
now if the assembly index of them is
really low right and they all they're
all indistinguishable then You' then
it's telling you that you have to go to
another resolution so that would be you
know it's kind of a signing scale it's
kind of nice so got it so those two kind
of are attentional with each other the
co the number of copies and the assembly
index
yeah that's really really interesting so
okay so you show up to a new planet
you'll be doing what I would do M spec I
would bring it on a sample of what like
First of all like how big of a scoop do
you take do you just take a scoop like
what like uh so we're looking for
primitive life I would I would look yeah
so if you're just going to Mars or Titan
or Enceladus or somewhere so a number of
ways of doing it so you could take a
large scoop or you go for the atmosphere
and detect stuff so and you can make a
light um a life meter right so um one of
uh uh Sarah's colleagues at ASU Paul
Davis keeps calling it a life me a life
meter which is quite a nice idea because
you think about it if you've got um a
living system that's produced ing these
uh highly complex molecules and they
drift away and they're in a highly um
kind of
um demanding environment they could be
burnt right so they could just be
falling apart so you want to sniff a
little bit of complexity and say warmer
warmer warmer oh we found life we found
the alien we found we found the alien
Elon Musk smoking a joint in the bottom
of the cave on mars or Elon himself
whatever right you say okay found it so
what you can do is the mass spectrometer
um you could just look for things in the
gas phase or you on the surface drill
down because you want to find molecules
that are you you've either got to find
the source living system because the
problem with just looking for complexity
is it gets burnt away so in a harsh
environment on on on say on the M
surface of Mars there's a very low
probability that you're going to find
really complex molecules because of all
the radiation and so on if you drill
down a little bit you could drill down a
bit into into a soil that's billions of
years old then I would put in some
solvent water alcohol or something or
take a a scoop put it in put viol make
it volatile put it into the mass
spectrometer and just try and detect
High complexity High abundant molecules
and if you get them hey Presto you can
have evidence of Life MH wouldn't that
then be great if you could say okay we
found evidence of life now we want to
keep keep the life meter keep searching
for more and more complexity until you
actually find living cells you get those
new living cells and then and then you
can bring them back to Earth or you
could try and sequence them you could
see that they have different DNA and
proteins go along the gradient of the
life meter how would you build a life
meter let's say we're together St new
company launching a life meter Mass
spectrometer would be the first way of
doing it just no no no but that's that's
um that's one of the major components of
it but I'm talking about like what if
it's a device we got it and branding
logo we got to talk that that's later
but what's the input what's the like how
do you get to the um a metered output so
I would I would take a life so my my
life meter our life meter there you go
thank you yeah you're
welcome um uh would have both infrared
and MPC so it would have two ports so it
could shine a light um and so what it
would do is you would have a a vacuum
chamber and you would have an
electrostatic analyzer and you'd have a
monochromator to producing infrared
um you'd add the samp so you'd take a
scoop of the sample put it in the Life
meter it would then add a solvent or
heat up the sample so some volatiles
come off the volatiles would then be put
into the into the mass spectrometer into
electrostatic trap and you'd weigh the
molecules in fragment them alternatively
you'd shine infrared light on them you
count the number of bands but you'd have
to in that case do some separation
because you want to separate in and so
in MPC it's really nice and convenient
because you can separate
electrostatically but um you need to
have that can you do it in real time
yeah pretty much pretty much yeah so
let's go all the way back so let okay
we're really going get this the the
Lex's life me Lex and Lee's life Lex and
Lee it's a good it's a good good uh good
ring to it all right so um you have a
you have a vacuum chamber you have a
little nose the nose would have um uh
some a a packing material so you would
take your your sample add it onto the
nose add a solvent or a gas it would
then be sucked up the nose and that
would be separated using Chrome what we
call chromatography and then as each
band comes off the nose we would then do
MPC and infrared and in the count in the
case of infrared count the number of
bands in the case of mass count the
number of fragments and weigh it and
then the further up in molecular weight
range for the mass spec and the number
of bands you go up and up and up from
the you know dead interesting
interesting over the threshhold oh my
gosh Earth life and then right up to bat
crazy this is definitely um you
know alien intelligence that's made this
life right you could almost go all the
way there same in the infrared and it's
pretty simple the thing that is really
problematical is that for many years
decades what people have done and I
can't blame them is they've rather
they've been obsessing about small
biomarkers on that we find on Earth
amino acids like single amino acids or
evidence of small molecules and these
things and looking for those run looking
for complexity they were the be
beautiful thing about this is you can
look for um complexity without Earth
chemistry bias or Earth biology bias so
assembly theory is just a way of saying
hey complexity and abundance is evidence
of selection that's how our universal
life meter will work complexity in
abundance is evidence of
selection okay so let's apply our life
meter to
Earth
so what you know if we were just to
apply assembly index measurements to
Earth what do what what kind of stuff
are going to be get uh are going to get
what's
impressive about some of the complexity
on Earth so we did this a few years ago
in the um when I was trying to convince
NASA and colleagues that this technique
could work and honestly it's so funny
because everyone's like no ain't going
to
work and I was just like because the
chemist were saying of course there are
complicated molecules out there you can
detect that just form randomly I was
like re really that's like that was like
you know as a bit like
a um I don't know someone saying of
course Darwin textbook was just written
randomly by some monkeys and a tyght I
just for me it was like really and and
and I pushed a lot on the chemists now
and I think most of them are on board
but not totally it re really had some
big arguments but the copy number caught
there cuz I think I confused the chemist
by saying
one off and then when I made clear about
the copy number I think that made it a
little bit easier just to
clarify chemist might say that of course
out there outside of Earth there's
complex molecules yes okay and then
you're saying wait a minute that's like
saying of course there's aliens out
there like you yeah exactly that okay
exactly but you're you're saying you
clarify
that that's actually a very interesting
question and we should be looking for
complex molecules of which the copy
number is two or greater yeah exactly so
on Earth so coming back to Earth what we
did is we took a whole bunch of samples
we and we were running Prebiotic
chemistry experiments in the lab um we
took various inorganic minerals and
extracted them look at the volatile
because there's a special way of
treating minerals and polymers in
assembly Theory where what in this in
our life machine we're looking at
molecules we don't care about polymers
because they don't they're not volatile
you can't hold them they're not how how
can you make if you can't assern that
they're identical then it's very
difficult for you to to to work out if
there undergone selection or they're
just a random mess same with some
minerals but we can come back to that so
basically what you do we got whole loads
of samples in organic ones we got a load
of we got Scotch whiskey and also got
took AR bag which is one of my favorite
whiskies which is very pey and another
another whis PD mean is like um so the
way that on on um in Scotland in Isa
which is Little Island the the the the
the scotch the SC the whiskey is led to
mature in barrels and um the the it said
that the Pete you know the the the
complex molecules in the Pete might find
their way through into the whiskey and
that's what gives it this intense brown
color and really complex flavor it's
literally molecular complexity that does
that and so you know vulka is the
complete opposite it's just pure right
the better the whiskey the higher the
assembly index the the higher IND the
better the whiskey that's what I mean I
really love deep PT Scottish whiskies
near my house there is a a one of the
the lowland distilleries called gleno
it's still beautiful whiskey but not as
complex so for fun I C took some Glen
Goin whiskey andard B and put them into
the mass Beck and measure the assembly
index I also got eoli so the way we do
it take the kyi break the cell apart
take it all apart um and also got some
beer and and people were ridiculing us
saying oh beer is evidence of complexity
one of the one of the computational uh
complexity people was just
throwing yeah we kind of kind of his
very vigorous in his disagreement of
assembly theory was just saying you know
you don't know what you're doing even
beer is more complicated than human what
we didn't realize is that it's not beer
say is taking the yeast extract taking
the extract breaking the cells
extracting the molecules and just
looking at the profile of the molecule
see if there's anything over the
threshold and we also put in a really
complex molecule taxo so we took all of
these but also NASA gave us I think five
samples and they wouldn't tell us what
they are they said no we don't believe
you're can to get this to work and they
really you know they gave us some super
complex samples and they gave us two
fossils one that was a million years old
and one was a 10,000 years old um SE
something from Antarctica seabed they
gave us IM meras and meter right and a
few others put them through the system
so I we we took all the samples treated
them all identically put them into Mass
Spec fragmented them counted and in this
case implicit in the measurement was we
um you in Mass backc you only
detect um Peaks when you've got more
than say let's say 10,000 identical
molecules so the copy number is already
baked in but wasn't Quantified which is
super important there this was in the
first paper cuz I was like it's abundant
of
course um and when you then took it all
out we found that the biological
samples um gave you um molecules that
had an assembly index greater than 15
and all the a biotic samples were less
than 15 and then we took the NASA
samples and we looked at the ones that
were more than 15 or less than 15 and we
gave them back to NASA they're like oh
gosh yep dead Living Dead living you got
it mhm and um and that's what we found
on Earth um that's a success yeah oh
yeah resounding success um well can can
you uh just go back to the beer and the
eoli so what's the assembly index on
those so what you were able to do is
like the assembly index um of we found
High assembly index molecules origin
originating from the beer sample and the
eoli sample so the yeast and the beer I
mean there there were didn't know which
one was higher we wouldn't really do any
detail there because now we are doing
that because one of the things we've
done um it's a secret but I can tell
you I think no nobody's listening well
is that we've just mapped the Tree of
Life using assembly Theory because
everyone said oh that you can't do
anything biology and what we're able to
do is so you I think there's three way
well two ways of doing Tree of Life
traff uh well three ways actually yeah
what's the tree of life so the tree of
life is basically
um tracing back the history of life on
Earth all the different species going
back what who evolved from what and it
all goes all the way back to the first
kind of life forms and they Branch off
and like you have plant kingdom the
animal kingdom the fungi Kingdom you
know and different and different
branches all the way up um and the way
this was classically done and I'm no
evolutionary biologist Evolution
biologists are very tell me every day at
least 10 times um I want to be one
though kind of like biology it's kind of
cool but yeah it's very cool um but
basically what uh what Darwin and Mel
and all these people do is just they
draw pictures right and they they taxa
they just con they were able to draw
pictures and and say and say oh these
look like common classes yeah
then they're artists really they're just
you know but they but they they were
able to find out a lot right and looking
at verit in verance Cameran explosion
all this stuff and then um then came the
genomic Revolution and suddenly everyone
used Gene sequencing and Craig vent is a
good example I think he's gone around
the world and his YT just picking up
samples looking for new species where
he's just found new species of life just
from sequencing it's amazing so you have
taxonomy you have sequencing and then
you can also do a little bit of kind of
molecular um uh kind of archaeology like
you know measure the samples and and
kind of form some inference what we did
um is we were able to
fingerprint so we took a load of random
samples from all of biology and we use
mass spectrometry and what we did now is
not just look for individual molecules
but we looked for coexisting molecules
where they had to look at their joint
assembly space and where we we were able
to cut them apart and and undergo
recursion in the mass spec and infer
some relationships and we're able to
recapitulate the Tree of Life using mass
spectroscopy no sequencing and no
drawing
all right can you uh try to say that
again with a little more detail so
recreating what does it take to recreate
the Tree of Life what does the reverse
engineering process look like here so
what you do is you take an unknown
sample you P it into the mass spec you
get a because this comes from what you
asking like what do you see in eoli and
so in ecoli you don't just see it's not
a it's not it's not the the most
sophisticated um cells on on Earth make
the most sophisticated molecules it is
the coexistence of lots of complex
molecules above her threshold and so
what we realized is you could
fingerprint different life forms so
fungi make really complicated molecules
why because they can't move they have to
make everything on site um whereas you
know some animals are like lazy they can
just go eat the fungi they don't need to
make very much and I um and so what you
do is you look at the so you take I
don't know the fingerprint maybe the top
number of high molecular weight
molecules you you find in the sample you
fragment them to get their assembly
indices and then what you can do is you
can infer common origins of molecules
you can do a kind of
molecular um um when the reverse
engineering of the assembly space you
can infer common roots and look at
what's called The Joint assembly space
um but what let's translate that into
the experiment take a sample bung it in
the M spec take the top say 10 molecules
fragment them and then
and that gives you one fingerprint then
you do it for another sample you get
another fingerprint now the question is
you say hey are these samples the same
or different and that's what we've been
able to do and um by basically looking
at the assembly space of these molecules
create without any knowledge of assembly
Theory you are unable to do it with a
knowledge of assembly Theory you can con
reconstruct the tree how does how does
knowing if they're the same or different
give you the tree let's go to two leaves
on different branches on the tree right
what you can do by counting the number
of differences you can estimate how far
away their origin was got it and that's
all we do and it just works but when we
realize you could even use assembly
Theory to recapitulate the Tree of Life
with no Gene sequencing we're like huh
so this this is is looking at samples
that exist today in the world what about
like things that are no longer exist I
mean the tree contains information about
the past I would some of it is gone
yeah yeah absolutely I would love to get
old fossil samples and apply assembly
Theory mpect and see if we can find new
forms of life that have that are no
longer amable to Gene sequencing because
the DNA is all gone because DNA DNA and
RNA is quite unstable but some of the
more complex molecules might be there
might give you a hint of something new
or wouldn't it be great if you if you
find a sample that's worth really
persevering and doing um you know doing
uh the proper extraction to re to you
know PCR and so on and then sequence it
and then put it together so when the
thing dies you can still get some
information about its complexity yeah
and we can and it appears that you can
um do some dating now there are really
good techniques there's radiocarbon
dating there is um longer dating going
looking at radioactive minerals and so
on and you can also in bone you can look
at the what happens in after something
dies is the IM the you get what's called
ramiz where the the the chirality in the
polymers basically changes and you just
get you get decomposition and the rate
of the deviation from the
pure um uh um en antima to the mixture
you can have a time it gives you a time
time scale on it halflife so you can
date when it died I want to use assembly
Theory to see if I can date use it date
death and things and and Trace the tree
of life and also decomposition of
molecules you think it's possible oh
yeah without a doubt it may not be
better than what cuz like the I was just
at a conference where some brilliant
people were looking at isotope AR
wrenchmen and and looking at how life
enriches Isotopes and they're really
sophisticated stuff that they're doing
but I think there's some fun to be had
there because it gives you another
dimension of dating how old is this
molecule um in terms of in or more
importantly how long ago was this
molecule produced by life the more
complex a molecule the more Prospect for
decomposition oxidation reorganization
loss of chirality and all that jazz but
what life also does is it enriches as
you get older the the amount of carbon
13 in you goes up MH because of the
because of the way the metabol because
of the way the the bonding is in in
carbon 13 so it has a slightly different
strength bond strength than you is
called the kinetic isotope effect so you
can literally date how old you are you
know uh or when you stop metabolizing so
you could date someone's debt how old
they are I think I'm making this up this
might be right but I think it's roughly
right the amount of carbon 13 you have
in you you can kind of estimate how how
old you are how
old living or humans are or living yeah
yeah like you could say oh this person
is 10 years old and this person's 30
years old because they' be metabolizing
more carbon and they've accumulated it
that's the basic idea it's probably
completely wrong time signatures of of
chemistry are
fcet